THE GREAT SALT LAKE IS EVAPORATING BEFORE OUR EYES.
SCIENTISTS SAY IT MAY DISAPPEAR
ALL TOGETHER IN FIVE YEARS BUT
COULD BE SAVED WITH EMERGENCY
MEASURES.
MANY EXPERTS BELIEVE WHAT IS
HAPPENING IS A MICROCOSM OF WHAT
IS EXPECTED TO HAPPEN TO THE
PLANET.
BILL WEIR IS LIVE IN ST. GEORGE,
UTAH.
BILL, WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
>> Reporter: WELL, DON, HERE IN
UTAH THIS MEGADROUGHT IS NOT
JUST ABOUT THE WATER THEY DRINK
OR USE TO WATER DROPS AND
ANIMALS.
IT'S ABOUT THE AIR THEY BREATHE.
TOXIC DUST.
THEY ARE REALIZING IF THEY DON'T
SPEND BILLIONS TO PUT MORE WATER
IN THE GREAT SALT LAKE THEY
COULD BE PAYING MUCH MORE
FOREVER.
THIS IS WHAT IS LEFT OF THE
GREAT SALT LAKE.
THEY HIT RECORD LOWS IN IN
RECENT MONTHS, EXPOSING 800
SQUARE MILES OF LAKE BED.
UNCHECKED WATER USE AND CLIMATE
CHANGE AREN'T JUST THREATENING
THE BIRDS AND SAILBOATERS.
AND HERE THE WESTERN MEGADROUGHT
THREATENS MORE THAN SNOW SPORTS,
AGRICULTURE AND INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THIS LAKE BED HOLDS CENTURIES OF
TOXIC RUNOFF.
MERCURY, SELENIUM, ARSENIC, SOME
OF IT NATURAL, SOME OF IT MAN
MADE MINING WASTE.
IF IT TURNS TO DUST AND ADDS TO
SOME OF THE WORST AIR POLLUTION
IN THE COUNTRY, THIS IS A THREAT
TO THE LUNGS OF OVER 2.5 MILLION
PEOPLE.
>> WE HAVE DONE THIS EXPERIMENT
IN HISTORY BEFORE.
WE KNOW ABOUT DUST STORMS.
WE KNOW ABOUT PARTICULATE
POLLUTION.
WE KNOW ABOUT HEAVY METALS AND
HOW THEY ARE BAD FOR HUMANS.
>> THIS IS AN ECOLOGICAL
DISASTER THAT WILL BECOME A
HUMAN HEALTH DISASTER.
>> Reporter: BONNIE BAXTER IS
AMONG THE SCIENTISTS WHO
RECENTLY WARNED THAT THE GREAT
SALT LAKE AS WE KNOW IT COULD BE
GONE IN FIVE YEARS.
SHRIVELED INTO FINGERS OF
LIFELESS WATER BEFORE BACKING
THE GREAT TOXIC DUST BOWL.
>> YOU CAN SEE A PERSON STANDING
OUT THERE LIKE THE WATER WOULD
HAVE BEEN ABOVE THEIR HEAD A FEW
YEARS AGO.
>> Reporter: THIS IS KNOWN AS A
TERMINAL LAKE WITH NO RIVERS TO
TAKE MINERALS TO THE SEA.
SO THEY BUILD UP OVER TIME.
JUST LIKE OWENS LAKE IN
CALIFORNIA, AFTER DEVELOPERS
NOTORIOUSLY DRAINED IT A CENTURY
AGO TO BUILD LOS ANGELES.
IT BOTH INSPIRED THE MOVIE
"CHINATOWN" AND FORCED
CALIFORNIANS TO SPEND IN THE
BILLIONS TO CONTROL THE TOXIC
DUST THAT REMAINS A THREAT 100
YEARS LATER.
.
THIS LAKE IS 12 TO 15 TIMES
BIGGER THAN OWENS LAKE.
IT'S RIGHT NEXT TO A
METROPOLITAN CENTER, WHICH THAT
LAKE WAS NOT.
SO THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL
BREATHE THIS DUST IMMEDIATELY
AND WE ARE REALLY, REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT HAPPENING
HERE.
SO WE HAVE DONE THAT HE CAN
PEER.
.
WE SHOULDN'T DO IT AGAIN.
>> Reporter: HUMAN CHOICES THAT
LED TO THAT CATASTROPHIC EVENT,
RIGHT?
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE GREAT SALT
LAKE IN A POSITION TO WHERE WE
CAN AVOID THAT A CATASTROPHE, WE
DON'T HAVE TO SPEND THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN REMEDIATION IN THE
FUTURE IF WE MAKE CHOICES TODAY.
BRIAN STEED AND JOHN LYNN ARE
FROM RIVAL UTAH UNIVERSITIES.
>> THE THING IS IT'S BIPARTISAN,
RIGHT?
WE ALL WANT CLEAN AIR.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE PART OF
THE GREAT SALT LAKE STRIKE TEAM.
OUT TO CONVINCE EVERYONE THAT
EVERY DROP COUNTS.
>> FOR A LONG TIME I DON'T THINK
THAT PEOPLE WERE SUFFICIENTLY
TALKING ABOUT THE LAKE.
NOW I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE INTERESTED.
THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE, THE
LEGISLATURE WHO IS ALL VERY
INTERESTED IN COMING UP WITH
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS AND
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS SO WE DON'T
END UP WITH THAT CATASTROPHIC
OUTCOME.
>> Reporter: IT SEEMS LIKE THE
PATH OF LEAST RESIST EANCE IS F
THE TATE TO PAY FARMERS FOR
WATER RIGHTS.
IS THAT GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
A LOT OF THINGS COULD GO TO THAT
EXTREME.
>> Reporter: AMONG THE SIGNS OF
CHANGE, WHEN U.S. MAGNESIUM
WANTED TO EXTEND CANALS INTO
LAKE, THE STATE SAID NO.
THE LEGISLATURE STARTED REVISING
THE WATER LAWS WRITTEN IN THE
DAYS OF THE WILD WEST.
>> SOMETIMES WE TAKE A STEP
FORWARD AND SOMETIMES BACK, BUT
IN GENERAL ALL THOSE PIECES OF
WATER LEGISLATION THAT PASSED IN
2022 WERE BIPARTISAN AND
UNANIMOUS.
WHERE DOES THAT HAPPEN ANYMORE.
>> Reporter: FINGERS CROSSED IT
KEEPS HAPPENING.
THE ONLY THING THAT CAN KEEP THE
SALT LAKE GREAT IS LOTS OF SNOW
AND EVEN MORE COOPERATION.
ABOUT TWO-THIRDS OF UTAH'S
POPULATION IS AT RISK OF THIS
DUST.
BUT THEY ARE FINALLY COMING
AROUND TO THIS.
THEY ARE GETTING WATER METERS IN
THE YEAR 2023 TO MEASURE EXACTLY
HOW MUCH THE FARMERS ARE USING
AND THEY HOPE KNOWLEDGE IS POWER
TO KEEP THAT LAKE ALIVE.
DON, POPPY.
>> THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT.